familias que exigen una respuesta el
cese temporal de violencia en Perú no
diezma al dolor y los reclamos de los
peruanos que perdieron seres queridos En
el contexto de las protestas para la
hermana de una de las víctimas mortales
el culpable está claro prácticamente él
ha sido asesinado por parte de los
militares o de parte de los militares y
la verdad para nosotros esto es un
un cruel ataque que hicieron contra mi
hermano no entre los familiares de las
personas fallecidas existe un factor
común se supone que para defender
territorio o quizás enfrentarse pero
también con otras militares en una en la
selva quizás pero no salir acá a la
ciudad en medio donde están niños
adultos personas mayores y hacer sus
disparos como lo han hecho y Es que
luego de la detención del expresidente
Pedro Castillo las protestas en varias
regiones de la nación hicieron que la
presidenta
boluarte declarará el estado de
emergencia una condición Que restringió
derechos cívicos y permitió que el
ejército ayudara en las labores de
control público
comunico que he dado las instrucciones
para que se recupere pacíficamente el
control del orden interno sin afectar
los derechos fundamentales de la
ciudadanía
a pesar de ser pacíficos en su mayoría
los enfrentamientos entre manifestantes
y la policía dejaron 22 muertos entre
ellos un joven de 15 años Mientras tanto
los problemas institucionales continúan
en la víspera fueron arrestados seis
generales Implicados En el caso de
ascensos irregulares mediante sobornos
durante la gestión de castillo